Hey, how's it going bros? My name is Peeewdiepie
We're playing Uncharted 4,
We just managed to escape from Scotland,
and now we're going to Madagascar.
In a train. I mean a plane (well done pewds)
Yes!
That was a close call.
He always copies me! All the time!
*Chuckles*
Yeah, how soon?
That guy is mustache goals
[laughs] Oh yeah we got...
That's not much of a clue.
Sounds awesome.
The treasure's bigger than even expected!
Hoe hoe, holy shit...
*Chuckles*
No that's all we got.
nate's got something...yeah he always gotta look at that sneaky bastard
wadda does it say over there...
i guess we got some advantages...alright OOOH that sony product placement!!!
*takes whiff of imaginary blunt*
that seems to be a reoccurring thing eh Microsoft did the same thing with their phone
man they are really...competition in so many things i never realized
stop lying to her!
she knows
*covers mouth* gasp
aw
dont lie to your wife, Nate, you can't do that
ay we're in Africa and shit *wtf pewds? we're in shit?*
that's awesome look at that
are we gonna drive the car? i hope so
hell yeeeeah
oh we are! *asthma attack* alriiight
chapter 10
yeeeaah *cough*
oh come on! again? faze blare *spits for no reason*
*spits again*
sorry i got hair in my mouth
whaoo
look at that fucking shit
i mean i can't see it now because of the fucking tree
can we go down here
no, no lets not do that
this game is so kewl i love it so much
road hog randles
heell yeeah motherfucker
lets go this whoaa god
might get a little bumpy
but we're doing fine
take a look...
what are we doing here exactly?
haha
am i supposed to jump across here?
'cause i don't think i can do that
this is a puzzle
where could i go then?
*randomly cuts...*
oh, we coulda just climbed *all veteran players face palm at this moment*
okay, got it
alright *is that a cap to something?*
we can do a little treasure hunting on the way, that's cool
hi guys
let's go
damn look at this place
so jealous, nate gets to do all the cool - aaah
look at this
pahahahahaha
fuck you * rip jennifer*
alright
hand brake
do some sliding
huhaha what are we doing?
yeeaah
you KNOW there's gonna be a car chase (is that so?)
the fuck are we doing? i love it. it's so fun.
so detailed
it's amazing
rickity rickity ooh
oh are we crossing that bridge?
oh i think we are
amazing
let's go
okay we gotta go up here
ohhh boy
it begins
c'mon bessie
cmon bubba
yea that's it
just don't look back
i'm so tempted!
always
backseat drivers (they are dead weight)
fuck 'em (agreed)
oh we're gonna go up here
ohhh c'mon
cuuuh mon
there it is... oh god are we going up here?
look at the mud it looks so real
ok i don't think we can go here
just take it the other way
iiit's fine, dooon't worry
look at this
this is where the lion king was shot
we're fine, we're fiiine
yeah oh god uh down here i suppose
fpppppht
ohh my spine its gone (wat)
and its gawn
do we go in here? (that's what he said)
hey buddies
wat teh fook
is there like an achievement for ruining all these?
i feel like there is, i missed one before
LET'S GO
not a problem (huh)
mmm slight problem (yeah)
big problem
this part is sooo strange, i never - (wut) i dun even know alright? fuck you
bitch
argh why did i skip that other one?
i felt bad for - okay we goin down here
and i forget
uhh its not moving
what the fuck was that
why dont we just walk, how about that?
oh boy... okay
okay i think this is our stop
yeah you just stay, old man
ah those sons o' bitches
well i better keep licking my mustache
lick lick lick
classic
classic nate outfit
mmm, so sexy
no chest hair, he shaves (nice observation there pewds)
oh, here we go
look at this veiw
its incredible
*le sniff*
aaaaah...
africehh
*more sniffing. wtf*
(africagasm)
afri - oh god i died (what?)
(oh. okay)
mmmmwhatcha sayyy rip pewds did sewicide
(facepalm)
i really thought i could do that jump
*sadly they didn't*
alriiight
now what?
supposed to climb this thing? okay, alright that was the key (wat fookin key m8)
got it
ooh treasure
*you have acquired the bannana dildo*
okay so this how you get up
ohh ohhh ho ho oh my goddd...
a banana?
bananah
i - i can guess what
get ready to get your fuckin car up
which button is it to hook?
i suppose i need uhh... a car?
aw god that's disgusting!
agh
no i know what to do with it, don't worry about it old man
mkay
let's not fuck this up (good luck with that)
oh you could literally walk
hahahaha
alright
i love how you have to walk around, its so fun
let's do a double lap
i can't, i literally can' t
can i jump over? i can!
huhhurhuh
just to be safe
awh shit
fuck i can't reach it (mmm whatcha say)
i seriously can't reach it *sssmuhahahaha*
well fuck it, one it is
huhuh shut up
what is he doing?
not even a problem
can't he do it?
alright back in the car guys
funfunfunfun lookin forward to teh weekend
i wonder what's gonna happen
there's obviously bound to be a plot tw-
gad fuckin dammit
gad - go up
we're gettin closer to the volcano
here we go, here we go!
no! bad idea! bad idea!
ohh my god
Fuuuhuahahh
OH, that's good
*wtf*
gotta take a shit
it just seems very unlikely that
they could bring treasure all the way over here
i dunno, alright
i dunno
look at that mud tho
so beautiful
i didn't know there was so much mud in africehh
(it's called mudagascar for a reason. smh)
or, in madagascar
alright, we keep going
all the people have gone here before
so surely...
(pewds? you alive?)
surely we can't be the only one after this...
ah fink a brerk somefin
where we suppose to go? here?
shut up
is that a weapon?
no? we got something
hey look its you bros! (rude)
i'm kidding, i'm kidding, alright calm down (no)
hi guys
found a lil token
not a big deal
glad we did that
*hmtuhh*
whaaat are we doing here?
oh, we go up here
*booom*
ohh
they're here (well noticed)
how is it possible?
i suppose they have a point as well
i don't like how he's lying to his wife
he's gonna get fucked y'know?
(only 'cause its pewds controlling him)
don't worry guys, i got this (yeah right)
yeeah
oh my god
what the fuck is this?
oh okay we're fine
are we gonna drive through - we're - we're gonna - okay
alright
follow my lead (that's a bad idea)
bimbadaboombadabang goodnight
*rip guy*
*evil pewds laughter*
oh god they got a sniper
aah its fine
aah aargh fuck's sake
alright, we're gonna have to take this
don't shoot me, AIIIEE
awkward
we should probably take that sniper out
alright i'll park you guys here, alright?
you guys just chill
papa nate's got this (pffft yeah right)
alright just listen to nate
or nateynooty as i like to call me poodiepie
alright (i should start counting all these alrights. pewds u need to expand ur vocab jesus christ)
we can deal with those guys
look how blind they are
love it
fuckin idiot
what is that guy doing with the box?
hahaha
oh god
push him out
so far so good
shuT UP
how do i get up here?
oh god, hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
get uup, get up get up get uuup
(don't pressure the poor guy :c)
nice
okay we're fine
ooh oooh hello
okay i'll take these
thank you
alright (pewds...)
how do i get up there?
here maybe?
i'm gonna get the sniper
and then fuckin sniper everyone
that should be fun
woa, dude, you're pretty cool
got the biggest gun too
alright (smh) where's the sniper gone
not here?
higher up?
ooo he almost saw us
he's right there
no bueno
what's the best way to do this?
alright now he changes position
okay
(that's noisy as fuck?? they don't hear that?? or is this assassins creed ai??)
i suppose we can just say hi (the genuine hi while looking down the barrel of a sniper)
goodnight
huhuhuh
*rip stealth*
aw shit, they got reinforcments
awh come onn
fuck (me)
alright (srsly)
*rip*
*directed by micheal bay*
dun worry about it
*hardscopes 4dayz*
yeah i - i did that
oh god i aim like a potato (i'm glad u caught on)
aw god that's just painful
alright
let's just......
alright (fuc k you)
let's uuh
try and suck less dick, alright?
i mean that coulda gone better (coulda)
who's shooting me, like there's so fuckin many
alright
i'm fine
everyone calm doown
just gotta get 'em all
guys please
baa buh ba baaa ba b-
(indiana jones for plebs who live in bunkers)
bish (yea u get 'em pewds)
my turn
let's do it again
fuck hahahahah
*OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH*
alright
another one
*FUCKING REKT*
uh nudder one
alright i think we can just go now
that was fun
*PLEASURE.mp3*
i don't think it's gonna be THAT easy (well i mean... if pewds can do it)
where's that car?
ah, thanks game
appreciate cha!
i think we made that a lot harder for ourselves
not gonna lie
0.o
m- fuck it
suppose we've could've just ...
driven on through
feels like i'm wearing nuthin' at awl
nuthin' at awl ...
oh god
aw geez (or cheese. the world will never know)
OAP -
SAHR -
SCUS -
S - SKEWSZ -
SCUSI
(u ok pewds)
OH, KAY.
HERE WE GO.
AAAAAAWW - SHH -
PFFFT
*mocks sullyboi*
deez pahrites really need 2 wurk on dere INFRAHSTRUCTCHA
WADISZDA - admiral akbar?
AAAND, DAS HOWITS DUN!
back it up
*refuses to move again haha ily car*
c'mon buddy
c'mon now
AAAAAAAWWLMOST there!
come on, buddy
*TIMBER*
WHOO!
YEEAH!
PFFT, hah
that's what she said
i'm so sorry
okay
let's see what this volcano's got
Ow.
'cause she's a bitch
(FEAST YER EYEZ, PEWDS)
(PLEASURE2.mp3)
awh shit
good point
look at this shit
(why do i get the feeling you're not supposed to swear in subtitles?)
(i mean, cmon, this is pewds)
(pls)
(pls?)
(i like my accuracy)
(i mean...)
(whatever)
15 years, "pretty much it"
fuckin hell
how do we know?
they ALWAYS blow shit up, like, why would they.....
*pewds goes with it*
okay
where're we going?
tahahhah
woa
i wanted to hear the story (me tooo fuck shoreline)
mmkay
why are they taking a picture? (snapchat stories these days. smh)
what?
okay, well, that's our way to get in, i suppose
*mocks mercenary*
"sure thing, buddy"
haay bahddy
that's nice!
Hey, got 'nades 'n' (dump)!
Oh!
That gun looks -- f -- like fun!
Awrite, let's take 'em out, one by one.
(sings)
One, by one, I be searching for somethin ...
(still singing)
something that would come ...
Oh, he's looking through the window.
Bye.
They're STILL taking the pictures?
R u serious?
Oh!
R u serious!
They didn't see me!
That's amazing!
Just one more --
TWO more guys.
"Alright, then".
"I suppose it was nothing".
Don't worry! It ...
*exhales with a hint of chuckle/scoff*
Alright, mate, alright. Your - you're the last guy, c'mon!
I wanna get him with this new gun.
Save 'im for me!
Ohh!
Bulls-eye!
That was fun!
Teh, heh, ha, hah!
(gasp, gasp)
I like that!
It's cool.
Wait. Was there more 'nades?
Think we could use 'em.
Ehh, kay.
Swear did I -
There it is!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, I guess we just keep going through!
HUP!
HYEAH!
HUH!
I feel like this game has GREAT replay ability(replayability isn't a word) -
- even though it's very story-based -
- because of the - the gameplay is still so solid.
Uhh, by itself.
Does that make sense?
(I don't know, you tell ME)
I don't know what I''m talking about.
(Whut?)
I'm just enjoying myself.
(Okaay ...)
Playing this game, a'ight?
That's all I got.
We go here?
Why don't we take THEIR truck? It seems WAY better.
(Agreed ...)
How did they get ... ALL those people here before us?
That's crazy.
Okay, I guess, follow the smoke.
Got it.
AW! Come on.
*cringe*
Don't lean over!
We'll never hear his story.
Should we check it out?
View's too amazing now, too, okay.
Look at this sh - (f-bomb) (crap).
OH
MAI
GAWD
We can't climb it?
Can we just talk to him?
TCHEH!
(heartbeat)
Hmm.
Oh, yea, it's been a while since Nate bes on an an adventcha!
Alright, let's get going.
This is so beautiful!
Mmm-yeah.
No, I don't see any.
This looks more like a puzzle.
This is definitely a puzzle.
Okay.
*ponders*
OH!
Sorry!
Look at all the boats 'n' (ships).
Awrite.
We're gonna climb this one.
I think there's gonna be a battle here.
I mean, I have a feeling.
(That ta-night's gunna be a good night!
I'll stop now, srry)
We can't climb?!
Come on!
C'mon!!!
Yeeaah. That's it!
That's it, m8, let's get some ammo, actually.
I'm not a kid, dad.
Kay?
Now what?
Where do we go?
Awrite, eye c, I see.
It's - it's ... tricky.
I like it, though.
Oh, so we ARE supposed to go here.
Interesting.
Always.
OAP!
OHHHHHHH!!!!
Cheeze-its!
That box was s - snice.
I like how he calls me "kid".
It's so cute.
Thaet box.
What if we need it?
FROG - let's bring it.
Wait, HE'S driving the car now?
Don't f*&k with me, Boxy, I f$@ked boxes before.
That's right, *woof*.
THERE IT IS!
Um.
... No? Okay, apparently not.
HOHHHH, GAWD.
Well, it's a - "GRENADE TIME".
Holy, SHOT.
Well, that's ONE way to do it, I suppose.
*QUACK*
Oh, they are (indistinct) too.
You KNEW there was gonna be battle because you saw - I saw the red crates, or whatever.
What's the other one?
Okay, we're gonna take THAT guy out.
Oh, 4 FOCK'S sake.
I shouldn't have wasted ALL my 'nades, maybe.
Oh, GAWD (x2)
C'mon, lemme reload!!!
Okay, who's next?
FACK - who's shooting?!
DAM. S. O. B.
Oh, man, that was frickin bad move
I'm trying!
(Try harder!)
Jesus.
(WELP, THAT"S ALL I COULD DO HERE. KURT F. OUT)    (u did well dude. i here now. never fear)
jesus chriist
oh
say hello to this guy
one shot kill, nice
oh
oh, fuck's sake
thanks buddy
this is getting intense, man
fuck's sake, i'm dead
no i'm not
*rip*
dammit just edit that out (no)
fuckin hell
*intense*
*boom boom bang bang
*kill*
*booosh*
*yes more bang*
*iufhiewrue*
hey, i made it-
never mind
where da fook is he m8?
there he is
alright
just wait for it
*pewpewpew*
well done everyone
*hmhuhahah*
alright
that was that
nice one pewds
good call
*hyeheh*
more is gonna show up now, i know it (is that so?)
goddamn this is a lot of work, man
is he driving now? no
just sitting there
(whut)
wonder if i can jump?
i'll do this way
so fuckin awesome
alright
here we go, we're in
we're inn
alright
let's go babeh
good times
good times are ahead
fuck these crates (no thanks)
dammit i missed
no problem
i'll come back to you later, crates
sorry, did that on purpose (yeah right)
not a big deal
surely someone found this place before us, y'know what i mean?
(pewds asking the serious questions)
okay, let's not hit the thing
let's not - someone put that - argh
sorry
thanks nate
i like how nate is criticizing the game
very meta, i like it
ah, we're gonna have to pull that shit again
yeah and alcazar seems like a nice guy who will surely just take half anyway
alright, let's do this
oh god
OHH
OOOHH
WHIT
OH
ah
we're fine
we're fine guys
JEESUSS
hold on a sec
no problem
what the fuck.
uuuh
ahh
gotta go back in the car, i suppose
can't fuckin climb anywhere
*concentrating pewds*
(is he alive?)
(no?)
*concentrating pewds*
its easy, not a problem
i do this shit everyday
thanks tree
'preciate ya
*hahaha*
*hahahaha*
*hahahahahaha*
ohh that's good
*tuhah*
alright, there's the tower
let's do it, i hope this-
AH GOD
didn't really look, did i? (nope)
its okay
almost
are we driving?
*casually crash the car*
yes (?? wtf)
can we go around?
yep
its a gate, which means another puzzle (no shit)
alright
climb? no
okay we gotta walk around
that's cool
i don't mind
(i do???? i'm tired asf rn but what am i doing? adding subtitles to you walking around a fuckin building)
its cool
just enjoying the view, not a big deal
very nice
smells good
go here?
this is a special place, i can tell
look at dat (ass)
you are right, nate, you are so wise
so wise
whaddabout here?
we could blow this door open
*boop*
*boooop*
theere it is
where did gramps go?
gramps you coming?
fuck yeeah
barrels (oh no)
uuhh... bookshelf
sam another one
well whaduya know about that huh?
i got one of these
*booom*
not any more
*tuhahah*
i bet you could find nates around
if you look around but we don't need to do that
'cause i scavenged beforeee
'cause i am a whoree
c'mon
what a fucker
wooa another sigil
ooo and this one is avery's
he's got a lot riding on this
y'know, fair enough, for a game
i have a feeling that alcazar is gonna get to our wife
(i swear pewds cares more about her than nate does)
because he did say about nate
and if he knows about nate, he'll find the wife
*sigh* which is not good for us
not good at all
yeah, where is the fuckin treasure?
look at that shit, it looks so fuckin cool
the amount of detail in this game just blows my fuckin mind
here he is
you were right
pull his penis
sorry, i'm sorry (no you're not)
*hahah*
*hahahah*
where the fuck did that come from?
*the moment they notice it the bad guys show themselves. smh game how cliche*
jeesuss
oh my god, more?
(me too felix, me too)
hey catch, guys, catch
*boomz*
look at this fuck
*uhfukhfkusrfhwukafrhg*
the fuck is up with you? (well yknow... you didnt shoot at him a million times or anything...)
oh
what the fuck?
good times are ahead, guys
another one
okay they're easy, you just shoot 'em in the head
uh oh! (we're in trouble, something's come along and its burst our bubble...)
*boop*
where you goin?
that coulda gone better (coulda)
'kay we're doing well
OOOHH
nice
that's it babeh
love it
okay i think i got 'em all
nuh *tsshhuh*
take that back
'kay, is that it?
good fun
let's never do that again
ow *hmhuhh*
just hangin' around,
not a big deal
what? what is that? (its fuckin bad news)
what is that?
what is that???
yeh we do
split up
i have  a baad feeling about this, maan
got a bad feeling about this
ohh boi, nate is sweating
i like it, so sexy (wtf)
chapter eleven
hidden in... plain sight
knew it before it even said it
woaa
holy shit
hi guys
just uhh, good ole poodiepie here
heya how you doin man? yea?
yea you sellin' or are you buyin'?
yea? oof
ooh lemme.... //wtf u on about pewds
hey, sc - scuse me, scuuuse, scuuuse me, scusmeh
oh, touched someone's ass (mine)
sorry i'm a married man (sad face)
scuse me
look how detailed this is
oooh that's some sexy shit right there man (kinky)
oh, discount
*hahaha*
*pewds has been mesmorised by nate's super haggling skills*
*not that he'd need them wid all dat u tube money*
what?
*huhuhuh*
you can get a treasure
this is a random bonus
okay, that's cool
i'll take it
this guy peeling bananas?
#don't judge
hey good fun man, live your life
fufill your dreams, man
oo- watch what you gotta do, man
woa these are awesome, i want one
(shoreline already stole ur treasure m8, get a move on n stop lookin round a market)
okay...its a weird change of pace to be here
yes please
can you walk around with your gun exposed?
in a city like this?
one thing about this game is that you never eat
not really, its not the only one, but y'know what i mean
okay, i guess we go in here
been hearing a lot of noises, its my neighbour
i don't know what they want from me
they think i haven't been playing it much
okay, well, scratches are implying this way
*nhuh*
damn, just damn
okay, i never want this game to end, i'm serious
so fuckin cool
oh another sigil?
they really fuckin hid this thing, man
to be honest, to hide all the treasure in one spot
that's a fuckin terrible idea
hide it in different locations
(pewds evil mastermind: confirmed)
oh woaa
okay
its climbing time
ahh i love this shit
its a puzzle, ain't it?
*nyhuh* i'm scorpion
*uhhuhahah*
oh no
okay, in this order
sallt- salt, that's easy to remember
okay where's the scorpion? right there
we gotta ring that bell first...
okay, we can do that
alright, let's do thiis
uhm, hook it up
like slapping a nice butt (ok...)
is he not calling him? (he tried)
oh my god
whaddo i do here?
uhm... i think i can do it
*uhhuhuh*
sorry
alright, we're going down
thanks
'preciate ya
uugh its so cool
goddamn
alright
and now... oh god, we're gonna have to be fast
are we going down, or...? yeah we are
now we gotta wait again
okay i got it, i got it
i'm stupid (glad u caught on)
my bad
or am i?
am i stupid? (yes)
what
come on, come on, come onn
nice
OOoOooHhH
ooooOoOoo
hah, asking him if he's okay
whaddabout me?
are we gonna climb this shit?
i think we are
okay we are
oh my gad
i'm nervous
k?
oh okay, i get it
we're going here
oh god
*euuueeu* its making me so anxious
HUh Uhuhh
go down, ohhh god, oh god
i thought it was gonna squeeze my fingers
jesus nate, this is INSANE
so fucking cool
i have the biggest boner for this game (for nate*)
like, i can't, its fully fledged out
c'mon
c'mon just jump, just-
fuck's sake
there we go
*hahaha*
alright
scorpio
i was
*DNNNNGGG*
alright
we're gonna climb this whole fuckin thing
jeesuss
uUuhHUh
okay
no?
we're goin- nate, nate pls
please nate
okay, here we go
hUhuUeh go
go, go, go, go
go, faster- OoOhHH my god
this is crazy
but here's my numbaahh~
where we going now?
i suppose we go there, but
there it is - oOOohH
he's dead, he's literally dead
*DNNNGG*
its cus i did it in the wrong order
i have to uhh do aquarius first
and this one last, so i suppose we...
we're going down later
but this is still the right way, don't worry
shoulda thought of that
uhm....
okay so how do we get up here?
uhm, i don't know
there's aquarius, okay
i see now
jum down, ow
what sign are you? (libra power)
*DDNNG*
uhh.. leo next
wherever the fuck leo is, i don't fuckin know
(he's asleep next to me. unless you were talking bout the sign, not my cat?)
getting his oscar, or some shit
i bet its the highest one
k, well...
i don't even know how to get the fuck up there
don't squeeze your fingers, please
can i go here?
good boy, nate
this is scorpio
let's see again...
leo
taurus...
leo. its right there, how did i miss it?
okay, well, fuck it
and that's taurus
its up there
could you stop writing for a second? jesus christ
(well i mean... i've been writing subtitles for almost 4 hours now)
ya nerd
(rude)
uhh.. any second now
any- okay fuck it
fuck - fuc k you
*huhhuhh* ohHhh
boiii, u crazy
i did this whole way wrong didn't i?
no? okay
good fun
its fuckin amazing
go up, dude
what, do you wanna die? (yes)
*insert angry taurus ppl*
this game really makes me miss ?? man
c'mon
*DDDNNNG*
there, you learned
damn, that's so fuckin cool
there's avery
are you serious? (unfortunately so)
ohai
thanks stair *tuhuhaha*
what does it say in th-
let's up up up up to the top
oh boi this looks great
are you serious?
okay...
maybe we can slow it down?
or we can climb, as always
its kinda what we do
ohhhhh
well, well, well
OooOOOoOH
hahaha
nope, that was not fun, nate
o - okay, we're outside now, why not?
oh
what the fuck?
are we gonna climb the dial?
i think we're gonna climb the dial
i know you're part of a movie but this shit doesn't fuckin happen
what we gotta do, wait for the time to pass?
i don't really see...
do we have to change the time?
i think we might have to go back in
if i could turn back tiime~
is there anywhere we can go?
uhhhm....
not really
can we climb this?
oh, we can
well then
that's so cool
love it
OoHHh
how are we not dead yet? i dunno
alright, i just don't know
have a couple theories, but-
oh, of course, we can climb here, of course
not a big deal
oh, we're gonna walljump
okay
alright
OooOOOH my lord
there's scratches here, you know what that means
oh okay
that's where we were before
the thing that makes me anxious about climbing so high
is that i know that we have to get down as well
*laugh* you know what i mean?
its one thing getting up
well, its not a bad view from here, i'm not gonna lie
people don't know what they're missing out
and that's another tower
*oopsy*
gonna have to ring it myself
okay, not a big deal
yep, not a big deal guys,
i do this every once in a while
yep that clearly was safe
oh my god
coming down,
i told you, we had to come down some h-
#rip pewds
i told - oh god there's - watch - eeeuuu
oohhh
its fine
aaah
fuck me
jeesuss
ooooh
hello everybody
markiplier here
thaat's putting it lightly
(NO FUCKY OU)
alright bros
gonna have to end that episode there
*smoochy* aah i love this game
thank you so much for watching (and reading?)
it means a lot to me
leave a like if you enjoyed it*
and as always,
i'll see you tomorrow with a new episode
*kiss da fist*
stay awesome bros!
~outroo~
(i made it to the end. 5 hours later. omf)